back here in game six in milwaukee this  was before the game  an interesting long discussion scott  foster and  chris paul foster one of the top rated  and most respected officials for years  in his 22nd finals game but he's not  chris paul's favorite official  perhaps his least favorite and paul has  talked about his team's poor record  as ayton misses when he's officiated the  game good job from eight in there  booker can't hit the three in holiday to  rebound chris paul doesn't think it's a  coincidence  it's nice to see the two of them talking  before the game  antenna the offensive rebound lopez for  three  i wonder what they were talking about  though  [Applause]  cameron payne just in the game knocks  down the three  and off of the miss the made three  monday williams looks at his team and  they want to go zone the first time in  the game  sun's giving the bucks a zone look